just a short time ago pope francis
arrived in baghdad for the first ever
papal visit to that country it's a
scheduled four-day trip
a very public show of support for the
local christian community suffering
under attacks from islamic militants but
the timing is controversial coveted
infections are rising in iraq
and there are concerns over the
country's security
chris lipsey is traveling with pope
francis
[Music]
it's a trip two thousand years in the
making the first time
any pope in the history of christianity
has set foot in the birthplace of
abraham of the old testament coming he
says
as a pilgrim of peace on his first trip
since the dawn of the pandemic
wasting no time since getting vaccinated
last month
to visit one of the most ancient and
beleaguered christian communities
on earth decades of war and terrorism
have squeezed them into the margins
says archbishop bashar warda of erbil
two-thirds of the christians left iraq
bombing churches kidnapping and killing
bishop and priests and christians
because they are christians that's
religiously motivated
the town of karakosh historically
christian was sacked by isis militants
in 2014
and retaken by iraqi forces in 2016.
today christian refugees are returning
and rebuilding
and preparing for the pope's visit on
sunday pope francis has insisted on
coming here
despite the many challenges and the many
people who didn't want him to
says this christian from karakosh
throughout iraq
isis and other threats have hardly
disappeared this past wednesday
ten rockets slammed into an air base
leaving one u.s contractor
dead the latest in an uptick in violence
from militia
and terror groups even deadlier the
coronavirus pandemic
iraq now averaging 4 000 new cases daily
with triple the infections in the past
month in a country with hospitals left
thread there by decades of unrest and
ill-equipped to cope with what some fear
could be a series of super spreader
events
judging from past papal trips abroad
iraqi and vatican authorities insist
kovid's safety measures will be strictly
enforced and note that pope francis and
his entourage have all been inoculated
but the throngs of iraqis expected to
crowd at his masses
speeches and prayers have not aboard the
papal plane pope francis thanked me and
the other journalists for coming with
him
and said how happy he was to be able to
travel again
next up he's meeting with the president
and prime minister where he's expected
to bring up
religious freedom tony chris livesay for
us reporting from iraq chris thank you
very much